all right team uh
that off on that live streamings on to
welcome for those who are watching out
on live stream
to today's council meeting on the
Tuesday the 18th of July
um I've got two apologies one from Tom
and one from Ellen don't seem to have
any others required somebody move the
apologies I'll move there thank you ring
and Grant
any Declarations of interest that we're
not already aware of
we'll just move on from that and we have
no public forum today and we have two
major Lego items and the public excluded
sessions I'll just declare those two one
is the future for Local Government
review for regional working group and
the second one is the discussion of the
local government New Zealand annual
general meeting
somebody like to move that we take those
on on thank you Leslie
you always up there okay
and now let's work our way through we've
got a number of meetings that we need to
minutes that we need to confirm to start
with
for the minutes of the uh Bluff Council
board held on then Monday the 26th of
June
Barry mood
any discussion about those
that they're being none all those in
favor carried
and minutes of the council meeting held
on the 27th of June
Alex
um can I please just note your wish that
my apology wasn't recorded for those
it's corrected thank you yeah
yeah so Darren thank you Leslie any
discussion about those minutes
he's being none all that's in favor all
right Kerry
mentally extraordinary meeting of
council held on the 4th of July
removed please thank you Darren seconded
thank you Leslie it's getting a bit
repetitive but very good though
any discussion
all those in favor I carried
recommendation of the meeting of the
infrastructure committee held on the
11th of July rang thank you yes I'll
move that the um a proposed right-of-way
name
um be adopted as Oak Ridgeway thank you
and I take it you're moving the
received the report as well yeah
yeah and and to receive the
recommendation thank you
yeah thank you
any discussion beyond that
is not
all those in favor
aye Kerry
on to item nine addressing the city
center untidy and neglected buildings
um
eight eight yeah it's very good no it is
number eight
I'm Cura tab eight
turbo sorry
um I'd like to take the reporters read
but noting that there's
um I think approximately seven pages
um there is a bit to it it's a probably
lead with an apology
um in regard to the title um I think the
title probably belies the complexity of
the issues
um that are discussed in the paper
essentially
um we're looking at buildings within the
CBD
uh obviously as times progressed um some
of the upgrades particularly with the
city block
um have cast a light on the Improvement
for invercargill
um and sometimes it can cast a bit of
shade on some of the other buildings as
well um questions have been raised
within the community this paper puts
forward some options for how it could be
looked at notingly
um currently have the Heritage program
for upgrading the aesthetic appearance
of buildings but obviously that only
applies to Heritage building system
queries have been raised as to whether
there was something else that could be
offered for non-heritage buildings
we took our lead from dealing with some
other local authorities who face similar
issues to find out how they'd looked at
it
what could be done what came through
loud and clear from talking to them was
that generally enablement got them
further than using a stick approach with
regulatory framework arguably the
regulatory framework the resource
management Act and the building act
they're not really set up to deal wet
well with the Aesthetics of buildings
so I'm happy to take any questions
sure Jonathan I've got a few just to
start that off
um when you're looking at option three
which is on
page five of your report on page 40 of
board books it talks about setting up an
incentive fund of 200 000 a year
um so is that is that built around the
assumption that we would
help fund some of the work being done
but the building owners would actually
do the work
yes so that's along similar lines to
what we have for Heritage buildings
which I am going to say I believe is
somewhere in the region of three hundred
thousand dollars per year I'm taking
into account there are arguably far more
non-heritage buildings than Heritage
buildings at the moment yes it's to
enable the owners to undertake the work
so with a quicker fix for this given
there's a lot of public
feedback on
um that we tend to be putting a lot of
money into ICL but the some of the
adjoining streets are not all that tidy
well not all that good with another
option to option 3B that um while we
have that amount annually that we could
actually do the work if we get the
agreement from the owners
well I mean I believe that could be an
option if you could obtain agreement
insurance issue well there's a lot more
sorry I think that
um I guess if we're going to touch their
building and use our ratepayer money to
to do that there becomes an issue of um
damage sought through insurance purposes
I think it opens up a whole big can of
worms for us
yep
uh Lizzy
thank you um
if there was to be serious
consideration of option three setting up
an incentive fund I would have to say is
the current chair of the city center
Heritage subcommittee that I would not
support that unless we had quite a bit
more consideration at the same time
about increasing the fund that is
currently available for the city center
here at a subcommittee work because to
create a new fund for private building
owners
who have non-heritage buildings I think
opens an entire can of worms that we
would want a great deal more
consideration on which is why I'm
tending to favor of the options
available the enabling Approach at this
time I think that's the most productive
way in the least expensive or Council
that will lead to some good outcomes
doesn't involve the sort of issues that
councilor bond has raised but allows us
to get into some very good conversations
as we've already done with a number of
Heritage owners over the years that will
lead to productive outcomes but are not
immensely expensive for us and
problematic from
Resource Management private ownership
points of view insurance issues that
that would be a just a can of worms for
us to open
so uh for your benefit jobs or comment
on that as well
um
about two years ago I did a survey
around tea taste Street D Street
Kelvin spay around that CBN about 42
buildings I thought at that State that
wanted needed work done
clearly not all in my Heritage and so I
think not doing something to the
non-heritage buildings is a risk for us
the feedback I certainly get from
commuting you've reflected it in your
paper is that it's no good doing all the
stealing work we've done around ICL if
the adjoining streets are not in good
shape now part of this should we put
ratepayers money into it do we have a
vested interest in the beauty of our
city or do we leave it up to owners now
some of these owners are in buildings
that have no tenants or very few tenants
they might have a three-story building
and only have a short-term tenant on the
bottom so they're going to be reluctant
to put money in unless we give them some
incentive I think and then even I
understand that they tried
and Georgie and a surrounding streets to
try to move a bylaw that required
building owners to keep up to a certain
standard and that was legally challenged
and fell over so we probably don't have
much by way of an enforcement and if
even if we wanted it so how do we how do
we get encouragement and it to me it's
it's a little bit you've got to do it
all or you don't do any it's no good
having four buildings that look really
nice and in the fifth building as you
cast your ID on the street will drive
about it it is in a disgraceful state so
this might be on it I think Darren you
wanted to contribute as well thanks me
Glock look I completely disagree
um I don't think it's our responsibility
to subsidize the upkeep of privately
owned buildings that do not hold a
Heritage status
the Heritage fund is there to recognize
the fact that there are those buildings
that have an increased burden and that
the city is here we value the Heritage
to help that be maintained our
responsibility in creating the
attractive streetscape is exactly that
the streetscape and what happens above
that is a private investment there are
some building owners that have done an
exceptional job with non-heritage
buildings I'm supporting option two the
enabling approach there was a process
that we're used to have at Council where
we had a ceremony each year which
recognized
um building owners that had done
significant work to the upkeep of their
building and making them look well and
the owners in fact you'll still see many
of these plaques sitting on the walls of
these businesses appreciated the fact
the city had recognized that they'd gone
and put in that additional investment
now at a time when we are very clearly
hearing feedback from people that they
are struggling Financial I don't think
we need to be going and adding another
several hundred thousand dollars to the
budget
an incentive fund of 200 000 and
Leslie's right if we did that would have
to boost the Heritage fund by another
three hundred thousand dollars I just
don't think that's in our purvey at the
moment
right
yeah so a couple of questions thanks uh
me Clark
um how many buildings are we actually
talking about and what's in the pot for
US versus
the private ones okay I'm not completely
clear on those figures so we'll have to
come back to you to provide that
information I can probably help you
right um of the 42 that I looked at
and there has been some development in
the last couple of years some of the
building owners have got on and done
some pretty good work
it's it's probably not it wouldn't be
anything above 20 buildings I wouldn't
think if you're looking at Tay and D
which are the arterial Street to wrap
around what we've done on domini's
um
say 20 buildings and how many more it
wouldn't be any more than that how many
of those at the iccs
that I can't help you with
again only to get those figures yeah
because um you know he what Leslie says
around you know the Heritage fund from
my perspective has been very successful
in so does that need more money from
Council
always
it would certainly be
preparation for Council
my my point here was that setting up an
incentive fund for an entirely different
class of building in private ownership
would immediately yeah I agree
have to lead to consideration about
increasing the incentive increasing the
fund for the Heritage building fund
because it would
it wouldn't make the Heritage building
fund look
yeah I think great players can see the
benefit of doing that whereas if you're
going to do something with private I
think there's a different one but is
that
attention Way Forward could be to invite
those private
people in to understand you know what
their need is and if there is a
partnership that we can form up and it
could be on a
in a percentage basis and potentially
that's option two really yes and one one
of the things that's been in
consideration
a couple of years ago was
the actual cost of doing some of this
work was dictating by the need to put
scaffolding up and there was some
suggestion from a previous counselor
that a cherry picker could could be used
to go to some of these buildings which
would water blast them and then paint
them in in a historical thing so they're
not actually doing too much by way of
physical repair to the building itself
it's just enhancing the what you call
the facade look I guess and how much of
a investment do we have in that as a
as a group of rape pies or do we just
leave it purely for the owners and some
of them are struggling I guess Alex
oh thank you Mr chair um much of what I
was going to say um Darren has actually
said but I because I personally don't
believe that it's up to all of our
ratepayers across the city to put the
bill for landlords allowing their
buildings to become dilapidated their
private assets
um if we were going to look at the
incentive fund I guess I wanted to test
the tables thinking around that rate
take coming from the center city like
bring fenced to the Center City route
the one that we currently do for Center
City activations and dramatically
decreasing it until we understand what
the uptake is my preference would be to
do that enabling approach and like Grant
said
um work with the landlords to understand
what their actual need is and whether or
not we can follow up the beautification
or the um refresh of facade work with
them with that smaller and ring fenced
incentive fund and also in doing that um
I'd be hopeful that those landlords with
the buildings next to them as they
become brighter and fresher there'll be
a bit of mutual peer responsibility
there between landlords and you know you
don't want to be the only one that has
them on your lawn in the neighborhood
yeah I guess one of the issues that
Jonathan's race is the fact that we've
put somewhere north of 75 million
dollars into a
the Ico and directly opposite the IC on
air Street there's some buildings that
look terrible
um
how do we I mean all we want to
encourage but the downside is if you
don't have a program of enhancing people
to do the work
the good building owners for one of the
better words will get on and do some
work and the
the ones that are not so good
um hold out and just say I can't afford
and you can't force me which is true and
then we end up helping them well what
sort of behavior are we encouraging I
guess that's the other issue uh we need
to be mindful of and if we staggered
over four years how long will it take I
think when we looked at it two years ago
Council skelty gave us the information
at the time thought that 42 buildings
would cost about eight hundred thousand
to water blast and to paint that's what
that was his estimate
so I guess
if we're doing 20 or less in those two
streets we're probably down to about
three or four hundred thousand dollars
but understand what other people are
saying
fresh is there any way we could sort of
do a combination of both so perhaps do
the enabling get people in they may be
able to form a partnership to get Cherry
Pickers or something like that to work
collaboratively and then we could look
at talk think again whether we wanted to
fund some of that from the um City
activation fund perhaps
I think the other thing to consider is
that we've got
within the next six or seven months
we've got a whole lot more street art
coming our way so the hours organizing
another group for 25. so some of them
will be careful where they want to paint
they won't paint over buildings that are
not in good shape they'll want they'll
want platforms I guess or
buildings have a reasonable surface so
they can subsequently spray paint them
so that that's something to consider as
well
nobody else
oh sorry
um
Jonathan just occurred to me that it's
not just
it's not just above eye level that we
have a problem anywhere that a building
has not been occupied for for some time
the area starts to become a little bit
grab it
shall we say and it's not just in a city
in a city problem either so I walked
along D Street the other day the
buildings that are occupied the foot
paths and eyes the you know the
surroundings are nice because the people
who own the buildings
you know somebody in that building goes
out and make sure that the front are
just nice the the windows have been
cleaned and all those sorts of things it
doesn't take you many steps to walk past
a building that is in good condition but
has not been occupied for a while to see
that there are weeds growing up
through things the windows are grubby
all that sort of thing so I I think we
over emphasize how much the
the appearance is about whether it's
been painted I don't I don't diminish
the fact that some of buildings need
more maintenance but I think the general
upkeep of the frontages which includes
your street Frontage of Windows that
that people can see at eye level is also
part of it so if in the enabling and
incentivizing it's also the things about
how you
maintain the space around you and your
Frontage and all that sort of thing is a
part as well if it looks clean it looks
it looks loved
um
you know I guess the upstairs part needs
to look clean and loved as well but it's
not always about repairs sometimes it's
just about that General as as councilor
crackett referred to the routine keeping
your Lawns mowed and and washing the
windows occasionally
um maybe it's plantains and things like
that
do we look at incentivizing those sorts
of behaviors as well
much less expensive than giving people
maintenance scrubs
yes thank you Mr I'm interested um
Jonathan there is indicated that from
his assessment two years ago from 42 I
think you said down to 20 buildings need
to be addressed in our city center we
don't know what portion of those are
ISSC owned but what I'm interested in is
what portion of those are actually
locally owned owners are we going to be
beautifying and we all know that we're
getting a new city center of course
across the road is going to look a bit
tired
um what portion of those owners and
those areas of concern are actually
overseas owners
so I can't give you exact numbers but we
do have a reasonable proportion of what
we call absentee owners whether they
live overseas or out of invercargill
again I can't tell you but yes there
there are a number of properties in
invercargill that are in ownership
outside of the city
so I guess my comment to that I guess
would be that
um while there might be debated whether
it would help a local owner or a
non-local owner again beautification is
beautification
and you just need to drive down the
street if every fourth
facade you've seen as in a it's got
flaking paint or it's got grass growing
out of the spouting and it just devalues
the work that's been done by the others
already
so Leslie thanks
was going to say if no one else was
raising their hand that I'd be prepared
to move the three recommendations with
option two
for the second recommendation I prefer
yeah thank you for the two of you to do
that I prefer to do one on Three first
so that we're we're not defaulting back
to going to another cluster again so if
somebody's if you two are prepared to
move there I'll put that to the vote
that we receive the report and the
request staff to take an existing light
touch as opposed to a regulatory or
enforcement type action all those a
favor carried right Leslie now on to uh
number I'll move recommendation to with
option
options
I'll just get two up so you know what
you're voting for
[Music]
so option two is the enabling approach
approximately ten thousand dollars
and presume per annum and a change to
the role
in your current funding on Avenues
available to the building owns if any
and just speaking to that is the over I
see option two not only is the best
option for the current time but also as
an not not just an enabling approach but
also an information gathering approach
which might then lead at a later stage
to us discussing some further ways of
supporting some of the suggestions that
have been made around the table on
beautification Etc but I think option
two allows us to collect a great deal
more information that will be valuable
in coming to any future decisions
exploring further Avenues including the
possibility that there's some current
funding ever news where as we've done
with Heritage buildings it might be
possible to have a group of owners
applying to a particular fund that
hasn't been considered to this point
and Jonathan certainly from my end
um if when you're going around you're
looking at those buildings predominantly
I guess in Tay and D Street which is the
Border area for what we've got in our
new work
um helpful if you give some thought to
prioritizing those buildings as well so
for example one down in their street
directly opposite the Ico Mall's got
some sort of cartoon up in the wall
doesn't look good
um just a few of them around yeah no no
it's not graffiti it's actually but
further up is it's it's pretty ugly
um
somebody else's Building without
permission so I'll put I'll put option
two to the motion all those in favor
aye anybody opposed
it's not cared unanimously thank you
sure we're just gonna have a shorter
German for a couple of minutes it seems
like we've got somebody in the public
that wants to present
so I'll allow them to do that if while
Mike will sort that out
before we go into the uh local
government remix which is a reasonably
lengthy document
cool
pad camera
thank you Mr Mia this is uh Dylan Graves
for his public forum issue that he had
asked to raise but um unfortunately with
my apologies my team uh missed the email
can I ask if does that mean that none of
the counselors received the information
that I sent through
no that would be correct okay so Dylan
welcome
um normal procedures you get up to 10
minutes to speak
um most people give us a little bit of
time to ask you some questions but given
that we haven't received your
information you have a bit of describe a
bit of discretion to let you talk a
little bit longer okay and get past
about quarter an hour I'll probably
start waving at you but welcome anyway
and we will circulate that subsequent to
your presentation with my apologies
again yeah that'd be great okay so I'll
go a little bit slower I've done this
presentation to a few other councils as
well and I've had to go real fast to try
and keep within the five minutes so I'll
go a little bit slower because you
haven't had any opportunities look
through the information beforehand uh so
what I would like to do is bring
awareness to biochar
and
biochar is
when we take organic material something
that was alive at some point so say for
example wood and we'll heat it up
in a controlled environment what happens
when you start heating things up is that
they start volatising off the terpenes
and the oils and all those kinds of
things the water and so on and that's
what we then burn off
and we do that over time but we restrict
the oxygen so that we get left behind
with a lot of the Char okay so that's
the unburnt carbon the black stuff like
when you've had a campfire or something
like that and you've got those black
pieces of
kind of burnt wood but it's still there
that's the Char that we're after and so
this biochar paralysis process can take
a waste product and it's more ethical if
it is a waste product
and then
gasify it and get this high carbon
recalcitrant product at the end now
recalcitrant is really important because
what that means is that this chart does
not degrade further once it's put into
the soil
uh conservatively they're saying it'll
be there for at least 100 years but
there's documented evidence that it's in
soils over tens of thousands of years
ago uh different people around the world
have put it in to the soil and it's
still there
so it's great for carbon sequestration
therefore
in terms of adding it to soil it is
really useful because when you've heated
it up and burnt out all those volatiles
What's Left Behind is a lot of Nano
tubes
and it's those Nano tubes then they form
like a sponge
and so it's really good at holding water
it's really good at holding nutrients
and it's really good for biology
it's this massive party Hotel well this
biology has a place to go in and live
and so what we can do when we've made
the charge we can inoculate it with that
biology
and if we want to with nutrients
although that that part there is
optional depending on what we want to do
with it so if we're putting it into
agricultural soils in order to actually
prevent things like leaching well then
we wouldn't put the nutrient in we just
put the Char in maybe with the
biological part and then put it there
wanting
it to hold on to those excess nutrients
so nitrogens and and some of the other
elements in a fertilizer
what that does is for agricultural soils
therefore it reduces the amount of
fertilizers that I actually needed
big agrochemical companies don't
necessarily like this but the thing is
it's got so many of those cascading
benefits
um
where we're sequestering carbon we're
using a waste product
the other thing I'd like to bring to the
council is the um
their awareness of when big stacks of
wood are burnt if we actually make the
fire on the top
and force it to burn downwards we
actually get a lot less smoke a lot less
um visible pollution there is still CO2
but
if if we light at the bottom it's
hitting the wooded by which smokes and
the smoke goes away
if you light it on top and it's hitting
the wood underneath and that starts to
smoke the smoke has to come up through
the flame and it gets burnt
so we can reduce the Smoke by like 80 80
90 it's lit on the top
so those are the kind of the key two
things I want to bring to the meeting
because I know councils in this area
have a large farming Community a large
number of property holders is the
constituents and so on and so I think
council's got a kind of an education
role here to promote those two things so
the first one seeing that it's not a
waste that is actually a resource
that land holders can actually earn
their Stacks top down less smoke and
then quench coin should at that point
when there's not so much Flames left
because when the Flames die down that
means all the volatiles are gone then
you put water on it or you can put soil
on it and then you get left with this
this carbon resource this biochar
and then it can be put out as
um as like normal fertilizer is in a
spreader it can be put into tree
planting into compost
um
potting mixes and so on theater animals
they're feeding it through animals and
in other countries already
so um yeah those are some options with
my show it's got all those benefits
that's why
I like it so much I'm passionate about
it and that's why I want to kind of
bring awareness to it
also can be used as a filter so in
stormwater runoff run the cityscape
that's full of pollutants from from all
the vehicles and so on it can be used to
to hold on to some of those things from
brake pads and
tires and so on
okay
that's a real brief overview
um so yeah I'd be happy to answer any
questions
um if you have them while I've been
talking
yeah I'll start the ball wrong if we
don't
um so you've given me a breakdown I
guess of
potential but where's the commercial
development of this uh the companies
that would do this
uh is it I mean if you talk about top
down burning does that mean that you
well not you but somebody would set up a
furnace type Arrangement where they
would take
a wood that's probably not of it's at
the end of life and start burning it
that way to create um
biochar
yeah
um or how would we use it at parks
division fragments like we have a lot of
needful uh water retention and
fertilizers and stuff like that yes so
there there's lots of answers there's
actually quite a lot of questions built
in there so one other company is doing
this overseas there's lots of companies
doing this okay
um I'd highlight say for example Sweden
so Sweden is using all of their
uh tree prunings and so on from around
the cityscape and by Charing it then
using that when they plant new trees and
they actually have the system called
macadam
um basically compost biochar and layers
of different sized stones and that's
what they use to plant their trees and
they've had a lot of success with that
and then in their plants that use that
biomass
to make the biochar of course they're
using it for district Heating
so they're you know hitting houses tens
of thousands of houses so they've got
these plants kind of set up all around
Stockholm
so
I mean
a city down here in the South could do
that we could hit hospitals or the
prison or wherever we need heating on a
large area so yeah there is a commercial
at
those companies already doing it uh the
next part of your question was how do we
do it in their Parks yeah in the Parks
yes again
um
it could be wood chipped and then put
through
uh either a machine that's doing
paralysis or it can be done on what's
called a flame cap paralysis which is
more like I was saying the stack of wood
if you burn it from the top down the
Flames are actually limiting the amount
of oxygen coming in
and that can be achieved also if you
have sort of a a container of some sort
so it's low-tech is a big hole in the
ground with a certain kind of cone shape
or a metal container with a cone shape
the cone shape means that the any smoke
gets sucked back into it so yes they
could be doing that the other thing is
the the future is going to be a wood
based future wood base energy so already
those companies already who've got
contracts to use up wood from
forestry prunings and so on and they're
pelletizing that and then using that in
biomass
Oilers water would be a really good
thing to add into that is get them to
sacrifice or get the people who are
using the heat to sacrifice 20 because
that's what it will be so if you put it
through the biomass boiler slower
less of it will get burnt and you'll get
left with Char at the end and overall
it's about a 20 sacrifice and that that
would then leave a whole bunch of fire
Char that could be used in lots and lots
of different situations so Alex had a
hand up to uh I think that's because
she's got a question or she might want
to go to Stockholm I think one of the
two yeah Alex
um thank you Dylan I found it really
interesting
um my question is is only one product
that can be generated into biochar or
Are there specific waste streams that we
could
extract from our current waste streams
as a city and convert to bio biochar or
bio refuel yeah uh anything that was
alive so it's been done already with um
corn corn the sentence of corn cobs you
know like um sugarcane
Harvest straw like it can be done with
anything there was alive so the obvious
one here would be uh wood trash from
land from from Gardens and so on
um
it's really good to set them up next to
Sawmills or paper mills it is also done
with sewage sludge
but that one you don't put the bar chart
in the soil but you can put biochar
actually in thousands of other products
like like into roads into concrete and
so on like that yeah so if it's
contaminated then it shouldn't go into
the soil but it can go into concrete and
Roads and things okay thank you and my
second question was is there any example
of this happening across New Zealand
here it's a chicken and egg situation
like commercially no one's doing it yet
because there's no funding for it
so but there are biochild producers most
of them are artisanal small scale
but there is an accidental by Char
production through
a biomass boiler in near Rotorua
somewhere that that wasn't set up right
and it was going through too much and
they ended up having these big huge
mountains of this black waste product
and someone discovered what it was and
anyway I can use this and he's added it
into his commercial composting
Enterprise and so it's slowly getting
used and bagged up and and you can buy
it in a thousand kilo bags so yeah
that's our only real Commercial Supplies
kind of by accident okay yep thank you
sorry I'm not sure which one it is
anyway even just the information being
fed out to the public do you do anything
with that you know like I'm thinking
about the wood fires for example you
know people could do that themselves
so are you doing
um is there any sort of thought to
providing this information wider
um so I'm not a Committee Member but I
am a volunteer for the biochar network
New Zealand so there is a national
organization unfortunately it has very
low funding and there's no paid people
in it at all everyone's doing it as a
volunteer and that's because we all have
a passion for this technology and we'd
love to see it
being spread around but obviously when
we've got no funding it's very difficult
there have been a series of uh TV
programs newspaper articles and so on
about it
and you'll see if you do a search you
know internet search on biochar you'll
find
you'll find over ten thousand academic
articles on it so it's massively
researched we had one of the leading
World leading research labs in Massey
University
but they somehow lost their funding and
so now we're actually in New Zealand
probably 10 years behind where we should
be where the rest of Europe America is
far ahead
uh so yeah it is
that's the key question is how to get
how to get this out to new zealanders
yeah
okay down
thanks for the presentation interesting
concept particularly given
the chance to enrich soil but with what
you said about
um preventing leaching and also the top
down burning being better for ear I'm
hearing land water air and going to say
are you taking this to the Regional
Council
who specifically are interested in the
health of those three areas as well I
mean for us we can look at how we amend
our practices but are you taking this to
environment Southland as well as a
concept yes yes I've been there you guys
are number four number four I've done
this this presentation so yes I've been
to them I've been to gore excellent
thank you and SDC
evil
look thank you Dylan but
the thing that comes to my mind is that
we have equality issues in this
City
um
I cannot imagine that this that most of
the um
log burners would actually burning this
material would end up being compliant
and I I or not that compliant but the
activity would be compliant because
you have to be have a certain amount of
dryness and all the rest of it and what
I'm not getting is the bit where the
material would be suitable for burning
in that way
um
so has there been
with what you've done any work done in
areas where there have been air quality
issues I mean we're quite quite
specifically
um if you're an asthmatic and you live
in invercargill you're really grateful
that there's not gold fires anymore or
those sorts of things that used to
affect your breathing how would this
potentially impact the rates of asthma
all those sorts of things has anybody
done any research on that and
yeah uh I'd like to say that it
the education of of like how to do
biocharring as as a paid job it's
relatively straightforward to show
someone how to do it one or two days
and I can get the hang of it and it can
be done very cleanly like I said if you
imagine a stack of wood being burnt with
80 90 less smoke
it can be done with
uh very low amounts of particulates
coming out so
um
yeah
does that kind of find the wood stove
and the wood heating issue is kind of
quite different to what I'm talking
about it's not really that related you
can make biochart at home in your wood
stove if you put a sealed container
inside with some holes in it
and it'll make really good biochar but
that's a very small scale I'm talking
about a little bit larger scale than
that
yeah but it can be done very clean so
larger scale than the testing of the
particulate
how much you know compared to say
palettes which people are converting to
how would that compare
yeah I think it's very similar yeah very
clean
thank you
thanks Mr Mayor yeah Dylan um look the
central government have given a
direction to councils to divert kitchen
waste from landfill
and obviously reading online here
kitchen waste can be turned into biochar
what's the how much energy because
obviously you try and light the kitchen
waste you can't how do you what energy
is involve to to actually reduce that
into the substance you're talking about
because obviously you need some added
energy to create fire or heat or Flames
uh the great thing about the by Char
process itself is that it's actually
exothermic so there's X actually excess
energy available from the energy of
whatever we're burning Okay so
all this all the machines and so on
they're usually self perpetuating so
they might use a little bit of fuel to
get going right but then once they get
up to temperature
they're generating way more energy that
they need and so that can be used to dry
the things or as it comes in and that's
how Sweden's hitting tens of thousands
of homes is because there's an extra you
just need to get it started and the
run
and that doesn't take long because then
you use your best driest wood to get it
going you might use propane whatever get
it going and then if you're bringing in
food waste you could be drying it
before it's coming into contact with you
know and you end up with this in product
or is it just Disappear Completely with
the food waste
do you end up with a biocharm you will
get biochar yes I mean the amounts is
probably quite low compared to say wood
but there is carbon in it yeah I mean
that's fine you're dealing with the the
kitchen waste that's an issue to stop
that tonnage going to landfill and I
guess yeah but I would add to that with
as far as composting goes adding biochar
into compost it really
um helps that process improve in lots
and lots of different ways so it'll hold
on to some of the nitrogen gases that
are trying to get out that do get out
when it goes a little bit anaerobic in
certain parts of the pile say for
example if you can add 20 to 50 chart
into the composting process it speeds it
up
it's adding more air it's a if you
inoculate it with your microbes it just
improves everything and it gets going
much much quicker and so
perhaps buy charring the food base
directly itself might not be the
solution but certainly putting chai into
a composting process
okay definitely great thanks thank you
Dylan and uh that was the shortest 10 or
15 minutes that we've had for a long
time but that shows the interest okay
thank you thank you and um yeah if you
can distribute that something around
then if you have any more questions feel
free to make contact
thank you all right thanks for your time
okay Council we're on to tab nine now
which is a local government
uh New Zealand remix and we've got a
suite of those so just intend to go
through one at a time
and uh you can have some indication of
uh Michael or keeper um record as we go
and what the outcome of e3 meters and
then we'll just then we'll move motion
at the end just to confirm which ones we
support and which ones we don't support
that gives uh brand of steer when he
goes to
the conference so the first one is the
allocation of risk and liability in the
building sector remit one
anybody yeah Leslie
um well I'll I'll kick off on this one
um
thinking of it from the legal point of
view of civil cases with the last party
standing I can see
why the Remake got put up by Queenstown
District Council but I have to agree
with the staff position that it doesn't
address the risk itself
and it's it's
not a remit that I would necessarily see
there being a lot of point in okay
supporting because unless there is a
fairly massive change to the Civil
legislation in New Zealand that deals
with last party standing I don't really
see see it as being something that it
would be productive considering a lot of
the other remits here and other work we
know our gnz is doing I'm not sure it
would be a productive way for lgnz to
spend a lot of its lobbying time okay
anybody in opposition to the
please discussed all right okay well
you've convinced us all Leslie
so we'll record that down
thank you excellent
uh rate rebate number two
and again quite some lengthy points
tonight in there
I might start the ball rolling by saying
at the very top of the uh
staff comments which is on the second
page of that presentation it says
that um
staff support the increase in the income
related threshold and I guess the thing
that raised for me was well that's nice
and it does help people out at that
level but there's still a cost to be
paid by the rest yeah
and so um because at the end of the day
we still need x amount of dollars to run
Council yeah so we we're shifting it
from one place which is
Patricia was looking at me then I've got
that wrong
shipping if you want to
come through you Mr Mayor um the DIA
actually give us the money yeah so while
we have if we have more ratepayers
receiving the rebate we don't lose out
on anything okay so there is no loss to
council other than the staff time of
processing
the rebates
your your paper your paper did suggest
or you input into that paper to suggest
that um
getting information out of DIA or and
MSD is not a simple process
correct okay
Leslie
totally agree with the importance of
rate rebates in the um staff comment
about being in favor of proposals to
increase the income threshold and to
raise the rebate level and I'll just
point out in the fact that the
government has just done that very thing
okay
um it may be it may be there's some
lobbying for it to go even further but
their head's just been an increase in in
both those
um however when it gets onto the other
points about the um
sharing proposals
I would agree with what the staff are
saying about some serious concerns there
um
about
just how
um
difficult and effective that would be
and whether or not the actual Target
demographic
would be willing to give the consents
necessary for that to have any
productive outcome
some
I tend to think this is one where the um
the actual
increasing of income threshold in
raising of rate rebate level has
happened was about to happen
and it's something I think that lgnz
would always Lobby for an increase
on I'm just not sure about the other
part of the remit and how effective it
is considering the resources it would
take up
okay yeah well
uh yes I think
um
for me I see the biggest
barrier for people to uptake rates
rebate as fakama
they feel
um embarrassed
to need to ask for support when they've
been independent all their lives but
having said that I do know that
a few people in my age group who are
still earning
feel even though they're under the
threshold because they're still earning
they should still pay their way on
things like this so there's there's some
there's a measures in there but I think
the whole sharing of information thing
between
um
you know even with our staff to to
access this information can be a barrier
anything we can do to encourage people
anything we can do to promote it
as God
in anything that puts a
um
episode barrier like access to the
additional information or
you know I I was a little bit
uncomfortable about you know making the
direct arrangement with your Misty I
have to say that people should be able
to buy in rather than it be sort of
almost imposed on them I agree you know
you're old and you're doing this and
this so therefore you must take this
hand out
um I think people should opt in rather
than impose but we should encourage
okay all right everybody else got the
handle Patricia back to you so you you
you're part of this it's got a little
bit of mixed messages I guess so what
are you recommending because this will
be we are the supporter we don't support
I'll come back to there
why um through YouTube the way that's
been written it's very hard to sure to
um the way the remit was written um was
very hard while we we're supportive of
the rebates we're not supportive of the
thing so it's a neither author of
against I suspect but I guess the Remus
not not challenging whether we have
rebates or not it's charging the process
as well yeah
and
and from Grant's perspective and those
that are going to lgnz it won't it won't
be a matter of I guess of debating too
much on this I think we either support
the Riemann or we don't Darren So to
that end I think we support the intent
but the remnant as it stands it's an
against it's flawed and it's also a Dia
process
any opposition to that yes but I ain't
got that one excellent remit three
rhodium transport maintenance
respect I know where this one's come
from
yep cheer if I may I think this one's a
bit of a no-brainer to support sure it's
got a large number of supporting
councils for very good reasons for sure
which we know quite a bit
um I don't think there would be a lot of
disagreement with supporting it yep
support oh that's right remit four low
collections accessibility
absolutely yeah it's like I think we
should support this particularly
uh since it encourages
um disability hexes and engagement again
it's one of those things that seems to
have gathered a reasonable amount of
support
across the country sure
yeah from my perspective the only issue
is the issue of the 25 which gets
bending around a lot by the people in
disability sector I would accept that
the fund is probably to help those that
are
disabled but
counselor your disciple because
I see issues you wear glasses and that's
what's counted in the 25 percent I'll
take it
and so I guess some definition of how
far that would go would be helpful I
guess but uh I guess we've got we've got
support there
rangi's looking strained I just wondered
if there were the disability people were
better under STV or in BP
that was useful that's a yes yes thank
you thank you I appreciate that one
ability to coach here at formal meetings
Alex
um sorry but do you have a commentary
um I would um appreciate appreciate us
supporting this
um I have been in a number of coaching
Arrangements now and it just enables so
much more participation
um in collaboration between obviously
co-chiers but also an alternate that is
already all over everything rather than
having to sub someone in
um yeah I think whether or not we even
use it I think supporting the ability to
use it will be advantageous for us
I've got a couple of other people up but
I'll let you go first before I make some
comments myself
Darren sorry thank you
um they're Kevin chaired a joint
committee meeting just recently yeah
well it worked fine I think we had SDC
and ICC and we could have had a chair
from both
outside of that I'm not sure but why not
have it there as a as an option
and it's also a great way of giving
people
some experience at cheering as well sure
thank you the deputy mayor and I are
currently representing Council on a
co-chaired committee which makes it
environment Southland includes all the
local councils and the Regional Council
on the issue of climate change
climate mitigation that is working very
successfully in fact to a large extent
is enhancing the reason
that we're about around the table in the
ability and discuss the discussions on
addressing that
um I I just think it is
um it's a good time to be supporting
arraignment the agreement that would
allow councils to have co-chair
Arrangements when it suited the councils
I think it's already been shown that
they have worked this successfully in
many parts of the country that
particular recent local example I think
is a good one and I'm sure councilor
Campbell would say the same if he was
here today
so I'm in support of this
ringing look when it comes to
um
standing committees
I don't agree with it I mean the
schedule 7 section 26 and 11 Government
Act is quite specific in a singular
chair for a committee and all the
regulations around the chair and and and
the way even the removing of a chair or
whatever it's specific to that so I can
see some work would have to be done
to the ACT to to have a code chair
Arrangement understanding committee so I
can see the sense for joint committees
no no problem at all so I don't know
does voting for or against I mean I
would not support it for standing
committees sure but I would support it
for joint Dramatics yeah I think it's a
having it as an option it's an option
it's not meant tree yeah Grant
yeah I'm similar to ring in terms of
um
the view
um I suppose initially reading it I I
think about you know
if you're needing a co-chair position
particularly in a structured committee
you know probably reflects the weakness
of the chair
um
because you know my view of Cheers role
was to
engage with all those members equally
work off the deputy chair in terms of
pre-meeting preparation all those things
so you know that's true governance I
don't see the difference
with the standard operation of chair and
Deputy chair versus this model so
um yeah I'm similar to ringing I think
with structure committees
foreign
and there's some reasons for that
um I think when you have a standing
committee it's important that staff know
who the person responsible for running
the meeting is and keeping on top of the
issues
if you've got co-chairs it leaves it
open that staff could play off one cheer
against the other if they wanted to have
a more favorable chair for a particular
issue or they might be perceived that
way then there's the issue of if we have
them internally of the cost Vapor so if
we have co-chairs of any of our current
committees who committee chairs and
considerably more than
base owners for a counselor does that
mean that they have to share the
actually the increase between two people
as opposed to one or do we take more
money out of the
the lower pocket of that's left behind
for the counselor so that means the
councils will get less because of the
nature of the coaches
um so I don't see any benefit for me I
like the idea of having a chair and when
the chair is not available because it
gives consistency and she is not
available
so if we want to go to the
the positive for those in favor of
having coaches just raise your hands I
get an idea of the numbers
one two three
Pioneer four yes
we don't get drugs
I've seen the Hannah was smiling so
we've got three and five of those
opposed
to you know collect clearly post me up
thank you
remit six is parking infringement
penalties
in the opposition to it being a support
of that remit none no not anywhere
that's a plus then you see sorry that
was me unilaterally decided oh good on
you yeah it makes it easy
um
uh Rural and reasonable public transport
while I'm supportive
um it deemed did seem to me that staff
Comics were very much playing on the um
climate change in issue that you know by
having public transport you're cutting
down the amount of cars going to and
from I don't think that's the selling
point I think our selling point would be
that we have some high desire isolation
so that can mean people living well out
in the country that
aren't connected because they can't get
in or we have some people that are
socially disadvantaged for one of a
better words that without public
transport which we often have to have to
fund uh would also be isolated as well I
think it's a much stronger argument than
going down the climate change issue but
other uh I'm Keen for that
transport advocacy work program makes it
an extra argument as to why we would
support it we know the work program's
already there it doesn't currently
address this particular issue it would
be useful to edit them sure yeah Alex
um that actually Leslie's just commented
on what I was going to so I'll leave
that thank you excellent anybody opposed
to that being a support
no that's carrying them a stabling
resolution services
we should support
yeah that's pretty much a slam dunk
anybody okay unanimously Carrie okay it
was quite Prime buildings
um
who wants to tickle that nobody wanted
to take
it's kind of like the the rates rebound
issue yeah the intent of it is good yeah
I think agreement itself is flawed so I
couldn't support it yeah
anybody else yeah
against thank you
yep
um
all right
number two yeah I'm getting there yeah
kiwisaver contributions
um so this doesn't personally affect me
when what other
um but I do wonder whether it um changes
the designation of elected members
because I know the legal members can
through ird claim back quite a bit of um
costs from home so for example last year
I wasn't mere obviously and I was able
to claim back transport
um able to
as an independent contractor a
percentage of my rights percentage of my
power percentage of the house are used
uh photocopping paperless went on I've
got about six thousand dollars back
um in text so I'll just on that issue
alone so there are some significant
benefits of not being sort of more of an
employee status and being more of an
independent contract because you can
claim some of those costs so I think
it's important to when you're thinking
about how much how much would I lose
from the employer not contributing this
to kiwisaver how much will I compromise
at the other end as well and if you're
not if you're not getting those sort of
rebates I just remember you need to talk
to me or somebody about that afterwards
because it's definitely something that's
very climbable
you may just have announced to a great
number of some
people
both on live stream and in the room who
were unaware of the level of possible
claimers independent contractors well
it's quite legitimate I think
I think this remit is it could only work
if the independent contractor status is
changed
it's not going to there's not going to
be a piece of legislation that is put
forward that is solely written for
counselors who are independent
contractors to be able to have kiwisaver
contributions in the way you hoped for
yeah
um it would it would lead to advocating
or elected members to no longer be
independent contractors which has a
whole host of other implications that
I'm not sure and you're quite right
there things like the indemnity costs
that we get
um on a personal basis our lack of
liability for uh health and safety
issues because one independent
contractors we're at the moment Michael
goes to prison if there's any CRS and
the rest of us look for his his interim
replacements
it would alter it would have a whole
host of
unintended consequences that would be
very wide and it would be it would be
quite a big legislation change sure
but even if it was a legal statement I
think you could potentially
lose more than you're gaining yeah there
no expensive everyone I've got you I've
got your ring outside of my skills yet
but
um the question that came up for me was
just is
we can ask
um as long as we were above the level of
contribution then set by government for
independent conflicts we can actually
set a tax rate for ourselves because we
not also asked for kiwisaver and I
recognize that this would be an extra
example payroll to do but could we not
ask for four percent to if we were
eligible to be paid and to keep us over
from our own
fans because we're not talking about
subsidizing are we we're talking about
taking contribution
what we lose if we take a day off our
employment or whatever and our employer
doesn't contribute you know it's less
going in weekly I I'm genuinely a little
bit puzzled about this but I am
wondering if it is possible that a
person who is eligible for kiwisaver
could save your payroll please put four
percent of it
my confusion yes I was
I'll just read the relevant part it does
this is awesome
yeah so it'd be the Best of Both Worlds
really allocate employer contributions
yeah
I mean look it is
straightforward I can't believe it's
actually here because we're independent
contractors we pay our own ACC we're
available to all the climbacts that
you've mentioned sure and and I I don't
know who which Council brought it
forward it seems Hamilton
so yeah it just it look the status quo
works it's been there it's clean
keep it that way happy to talk to
anybody after the meeting about the ird
stuff if you don't already know
all right that's clearly against thank
you it's clearly yes thank you yeah
yeah all at New Zealand fee sport oh I
would say I would I would say there's no
doubt at all yeah
[Music]
in the opposition to the uh remit a
level
and then we've got Knight of nine which
is local government agenda
so I'll quickly just speak to that Mr
Mayor
um and the lgnz AGM uh meeting agenda
that came out item nine was listed there
um item nine was seeking to form a
consensus of councils on how to proceed
in response to the Future for local
government report uh specifically being
ready to Target any income and
government post the October elections
um so it was something that was
important for uh Council to give
direction to councilor Germany when he's
coming to vote
um
on this item and from a staff point of
view we would just unsure that consensus
was quite the right word uh trying to
find consensus among all of local
government as to our response for the
future of local government report which
Herald has many recommendations
um we just weren't sure that was the
right word that been said it's an lgnz
matter so that was
the reason for this item was so that you
could discuss that item so that Council
of Germany knew which way he was going
to vote uh
and with that I will bow out so given
that we're discussing them at a little
later we don't have a position that
we're able to um so
um later you're discussing uh the
presidency and vice presidency yes
aren't we we're also receiving a late
document that is simply the presidency
and vice presidency
um
sure yeah
I'm reinforced
that come as from LG
taking this to the AGM has come as a
direct result from the National Council
and wider algae NZ really understanding
that they took the wrong course of
action throughout three Waters and
really don't want to be repeating the
same mistakes so what they're using the
I guess the ship or the vehicle of the
AGM to do is to take stock of the
community sentiment or their
membership-based sentiment as to what
they think that what we think is the
appropriate action for lgnz to take on
future for local government so they're
not going straight into negotiations
with government on our behalf they're
not doing the advocacy work until they
get a really good steer from our wider
membership base all of the councils
across New Zealand ideally consensus
would be fantastic obviously with 70 one
councils across the country that's
probably not going to be achieved but
what will do is give us a much more
concrete position of the things that we
as a collective really want to push back
on and Advocate on and those that we
don't
thank you ringy
no no I'm just sorry no no I'm sorry
Alex
uh I was just going to say on this one I
mean there's no there's no um
there's no motion and there's no no no
no it's only an indication and I and I
just think having read it
um
consensus probably is the wrong word
majority Collective yeah it might be a
better way of phrasing it yeah um I I
just think um in in the way of informing
a voting delegate I think we definitely
want to be involved in this conversation
and if possible be in the Walker but
certainly be part of the conversation
and because of the um somewhat urgency
of it
um because to some extent after the
October
election date no rather focuses the mind
um I think the unique chance to discuss
it and have our delicate participate in
that discussion with the idea that a
majority Collective position could be
reached
um is well worth supporting yeah
I'll just give a personal view on that
um I'm a bit nervous about this it you
know when it talks about being the
Walker but not of the commute to where
the walking is actually going I mean who
would want to be party to that
um and I think there's still an element
that we need to have some degree of
autonomy a good example is that part of
the
report that it's referring to covers
relationships with ewe
um models are funding but more
importantly the potential for
amalgamation of councils and so um let's
come up at our last
mural forum and staff are doing a paper
on it which I was feeling nervous about
because one of the issues about
amalgamation is that if you look quite
clinically from a southern perspective
you'd argue that one Council to cover
all this out them would be a good option
but when you look purely in our position
and you look at the other two councils
going anywhere between eight and
thirteen percent rate increases and that
will not be a one-off that'll be an
ongoing thing and you mix Us in at five
and a half percent
um our rate payers will not thank you
for that so um so for us we need to
still need to have autonomy our the ACT
requires us to primarily focus on the
well-being of our rate payers not the
well-being of the country that's that's
a government job to do that to look at
the much bigger picture so you know when
we're weighing up whether we get into
bed with the other councils then you we
would need to be saying is there economy
a scale are there shared services that
we can get some fiscal fiscal benefit
out that would offset the fact that
we'll pay higher rates which is a little
bit like the three Waters model so
I guess I'm just a little bit nervous
about getting too much into being all
running together
um but again it's not asking us so that
it's just I know what uh lgn's doing
they're trying to
um
not be ahead of what the membership want
I think they're trying to get a bit of a
consensus so that's okay too yeah Leslie
I think cute it's it's also
the one chance
for a lobbying organization which I'll
see GNC those in this case
um to have something ready as a paper
for the incoming government sure and the
the worth of being in the pool of papers
which the income incoming government
will have as briefing papers to read is
in my opinion too valuable to not be
part of the conversation if our gnz
misses the opportunity on
an important issue like the future of
local government to have a um briefing
paper for the incoming government to
lock it after the October elections I
think we would all regret it for many
years to come it's just it's just an
it's an opportunity that comes once
once every three years why wouldn't you
take it yeah
I'll come back to you one just wanted to
comment on Lucy's saying and that was a
good point
um so some users will already know that
I've had a meeting last week was
um some people from Erie
um
Great South
uh some of our staff and some of our
elected members to try and look at what
we do before we get to Beyond 2025 which
is still a couple of years away and
there's some stuff and they've got 40 in
work streams but there are some stuff we
can't wait for so the three that we
can't wait for is housing so I've got uh
a couple of councilors that are involved
with the housing portfolio fresh water
and the security of that water and the
issue that we probably can't control
what we need to Signal which is
renewable energy that when Southland
will run out of 2030 unless we do
something quickly so I'm doing exactly
what you said Leslie I'm going to draw
up a little wee booklet around and
sitting up there she agreed to help me
with that
you didn't agree to help me didn't you
yeah looking around the room
um because I've had MPS approach me to
say hey look it'll be really good on day
one if we knew invercar will need x
amount of dollars for housing a couple
of other things you need to support on
we can walk away and deal with the North
Island which has got all that all that
cyclone and other recovery
um tell us what you need in the first
couple of years and then we'll leave you
alone and so I'll try and try I'm about
to do that
when I come back the downside of it is
my colleagues and the other two councils
are not happy that I'm sort of going at
a little bit alone and want more of a
reasonable picture but my answer to that
was well if we can get 100 houses here
in Southland that will help us with
economic development around green
hydrogen and aquaculture certainly the
stuff based in our uh and and further
into buff that's a really good thing for
us whether you need three or four houses
and oh high night caps because they have
been quality there is not good enough
it's another issue we're not we're not
tackling quality we're taking shortage
of houses and we've got a lot of steps
to do that so I'm working away on that
and there's an area source of concern
but I don't actually quite rightly
simply I don't want to miss the boat on
day one with whoever the government is
somebody else had the handle oh sorry
Evelyn
so I don't think there's a
kind of a city application for itself
what this was asking is I believe is
where we go as a collective where we on
a majority basis recognize that
something needs to change for instance I
think most of most Council would say
um we'd love the government to talk to
us about rates versus taxes for
infrastructure items or something like
that it'd be really helpful I think if
our gnc'd know that most councils were
supportive of that dialogue in one way
or another now are they going to come to
us on an issue by issue basis to ask us
about that or do we have to commit
um
do we have to commit to to be in the
consensus for everything or them what is
it I couldn't form majority looking for
everything I don't really know that we
can do that without knowing
where the thinking is whether we'll get
more idea out of the conference is
something that I'm not clear on but
are we committed to the
um to mandating
lgnz to talk to government on our behalf
without committing us to of course's
election that we have not agreed to a
position and I think that's probably you
know
um there are things I think that most
councils would have similar sorts of
feelings about there may be others where
we diverge quite markedly because of
what our local
situations are
where's the happy medium and all of that
and what do we Empower our gmz to do in
these conversations with with
the electrical and unrelated government
yeah but to me from what I've heard from
lgnz they they're not looking for a
council by Council picture what they
need they're looking for the big issues
and certainly the big issues are
relations with ewe the possibility of
amalgamation and that's not a quick fix
because as much as you might want to get
into beer with other
with other councils
why record tried twice I think in the
last decade to combine four small
councils and each time the local
government commission has turned them
down
and Hawke's Bay have also tried them and
been turned down as well so a lot of
legislation needs to change before
councils can't self-determine whether
they want to cohabit with other councils
as well it's not just us put your hand
up saying let's get it done and do it
and the other issue I think that leaves
me touched on or you did as well
everyone was the issue of models of
funding you know do they take GST off
rates do they give us back some some tax
funding for some of the years that would
drastically short on certainly around
roading and other things there will be
the big ticket items that they'll be
going for and I think they accommodate
everybody
um
Alex did you have you yeah I just wanted
to um I guess clarify for Evelyn because
I think I was picking up that um you
know where do we find that happy medium
between asking the membership base and
allowing ldnc to play their part in the
advocacy role that they do with central
government and
um I guess just wanted to assure you
that they've developed a significance
and gave engagement policy that
addresses what you know like what tests
and what Frameworks are there in place
that actually whatever comes up either
needs to go to the membership base or
whether or not they can pull the trigger
and just make sure that they get some
traction for us as a as a membership
group yeah it exists now and I think
even even raise the issues of the gray
areas in between that yeah so there are
common
ly used that all councils have with gulp
central government needing resolved at
the other end of the scale is what we
individually need but there is some gray
area that lgnz has struggled with in the
past so good example is the issue of
three Waters
um where you could argue that of the six
seven councils and Tiger's health
similar not waitaki
no seven Council and and
otago South and which is a region that
we're now in all but invercargill would
probably be in favor of it so do we then
in that gray area get lost because
clearly it's not advantage to us
um but the issue is do we advocate for
Airway pads or do we think about the
national good what a good words and
that's the gray area
yeah somebody hit the hand up on the
song oh sorry Barry
yeah it's the wastenet things worries me
if we're going to mail them out with
these other councils or forces okay
um it's been a debacle when
why isn't it just trying to get anything
done
worries me that
air rate payers have been paying for
you know getting their infrastructure
back up
so interesting and you're quite right
the interesting
um issue for me is
um
I don't want us to lose opportunities
that Leslie referred to on day one after
the election
um trying to coordinate four other three
other councils I'll never get there and
I wasting is a good example of that yeah
um
I heard about this idea of putting in a
two-year plan from an MP that told me
another another Council was doing
something similar not quite the same
um being but being very specific to
their ta
um I thought geez they're going to do it
I should get into but chronicum is my
colleagues to go down that track
just gets too political
this can't get consensus so
lazy
is instructing our delegate to be part
of a conversation about the very
important future for local government
document which
which might come to the to some
agreements about what are the most
important parts or the most important
recommendations
to be highlighting to the incoming
government from lgnz that it can only be
a productive thing to do I mean it's a
it's a huge document if there is able to
be some Meeting of Minds at the lgnz
conference that you know the most
important things to us are the financial
issues over the wrong stuff for the
housing or the
um
whatever I just think having a delegate
being part of the conversation that
might actually come out with some
hesitate to use the consensus some
agreed position on the most important of
the recommendations that can only be a
good thing
all right
yeah
um
I find it a bit of an odd process in the
way that they're asking for a mandate
um
and I suspect it's because they've lost
the trust of local government Group by
just simply supporting this they get
their trust back the way a new prisoner
elected
um you would suspect that they would
quickly grasp the needle around seeing
the Opportunities Council soap was
highlighted around the new a change of
government or you know government
post October and and not miss the
opportunity off the back of that Local
Government Review to highlight
the the key things which they've already
done in there report to us where they've
pulled out the things that they like and
they don't like and we've got the
opportunity and I'd say natural process
is just they come and say well which
ones are these do you like enough that's
the intent and that's what's the intent
to the room yeah
I'm you know as a delegate I represent
the group but my personal viewers this
is a bit sort of
um too generalist and it's not clear
enough around what's been tried to
achieve and so my suspicion is that it's
a sort of a way of trying to Corral the
room yes and um be able to leave and
then go and say well you know we've got
to support everyone and I think they
need to earn that trust and that starts
with a new president whoever that is and
that's my take on it as well
um
it's a good view to hear
um lgnz uh struggling on on two big
issues recently and realize they've gone
down the wrong path so they're trying to
so the first issue that went down the
wrong path was the approach they took
with Dia over three orders where they
signed an mou that had a you will not
criticize in it and while it was only
one line it was just unconceivable
they'd go down that line and then they
took two million dollars
from DIA to promote three Waters and for
an embassy group that was damaging they
lost a lot of members because of that
with a lot of support from their
membership the other issue is the thorny
issue of uh Auckland pulling out of
local government New Zealand so if
you've been watching the tea leaves up
there
um local government New Zealand a front
up on the day and wanted to talk to the
paper that was going to pull them out
22 votes it was split down the middle
and it was the Mayors casting so that's
a correct
your worship uh out of all of the
community boards yeah over three
quarters of them voted to retain our gen
Zed all of the community well majority
vast majority of the community boards
did it was the councilors that sit at
the top end of on Auckland city council
that
um the mayor used his casting vote so 50
50 split so the council actually went
against the ma the vast majority of
theater that's not the issue I'm getting
to the issue I'm getting to is is that
local government New Zealand then
approached those Community boards and
see we are here to help you and support
you now if you want to get Mia Brown and
Auckland back into the fold you don't go
and undermine him locally after such a
sensitive vote I mean I thought that was
a really bad call so again they're
trying to recover back and critically
they're doing that because we need to
get the membership behind some of the
stuff
um but anyway you're writing your
assumption grad
um
am I allowed to speak to that
for just four on LG NZ has yep correct
it's a rebuilding example that's a good
thing
but being mindful that we've still got
some
councils uh talking about pulling out so
it's it's it's a recovery action that
needs to be that otherwise we'll lose
our combined voice I just if I can yup
your worship just to address that it's
the local boards themselves that went to
lgnz to help Foster negotiations as to
whether or not they could obtain
individual or local board level
membership it wasn't local government
New Zealand
undermining mere Wayne Brown that's not
what they told us that the local
government Commons I said they're not
that specific question that's I said on
National campus
um that's what they told me
um
and councilor potential is the alternate
has a steer absolutely uh so we could
get some mover and seconded so we can
get these
shaking thank you Lauren
your post
no thank you
on the table now
so proactive release of local government
official information and meeting Jack
yeah take it oh do you want to talk that
Michael I will and very briefly outline
uh that paper thank you mere Clark
um so this is this paper came as a
result of some questions asked I think
it was at the last risk and Assurance
committee meeting I've been finding some
projects about when we actually get
around to releasing uh some of our
papers
uh so this confirms further to what for
those of you who attended risk and
Assurance today
um Peter pattern had referred to you
um as we had essentially worked out that
something had gone wrong the system
wasn't working as we thought it should
uh so we
took the opportunity to have a look how
we release papers that were in public
excluded
so that's our officer reports but also
ultimately the minutes so that nothing
stays secret forever because it was a
very clear direction from the Ombudsman
when he came down
and did his own motion investigation of
us that we needed to get that sorted so
in the build up to the last election we
had started work on that
um with a new workflow system from our
internal and document Management Systems
uh that unfortunately
um seemed to over complicate itself
which meant there was quite a bit of
effort from staff to get these papers uh
released even with relatively simple
predictions
um so we have taken that opportunity to
reset it have developed a what we hope
to be a more streamlined system that
will get public excluded reports
out staff will still as you'll notice on
all the public excluded reports will
recommend when a report should be able
to be released somewhere immediately
after a meeting
some are within a certain time period
like the conclusion of negotiations
there will always be those reports that
can never be released and a good example
of those is often those that have
subject to Legal privilege
and so we hope that that will get reset
and you should start seeing our public
excluded reports come through on our
website uh early in August once those
first reports come through we will send
you a link so you can see where they all
are just so you know that that's
happening uh the idea is that we will go
back to the start of this trainium and
start releasing
you know proactively going forward all
reports will go through that but we're
backwards to capture everything since
the start of this trainium and then with
time we also hope to be able to capture
uh reports that cover um significant
um events or developments in the city so
the museum is obviously a very good one
where we can start releasing some of
that information that has been locked
away since for example at 2018
um for no good valid reason anymore
so it's probably a brief summary of
what's happened and where we've got to
and what we're doing and I will be happy
to answer any questions
yeah I've got some Michael for both
Michaels in the both are supportive of
this paper it seemed to me this seems to
be an approach from ligoma and it says
encounters are not able to make
decisions on the release or otherwise of
information
but I guess he's the local government
act as well and we in the example with
the last Fortnight so where we debated
for probably three quarters an hour
staff about whether we would allow the
three Waters discussion to be in public
as opposed to not in public
and I guess um it makes me nervous of
this paper tends to put the control
um we'll seem to put the control totally
back into the area of
of Staff making decisions on it and I
think um as elected members that that's
uh the dicey area that we're going to
because if you think about that in that
meeting we had the other day we did
release the information but not the part
that came from DIA we or I would have
preferred to release both
um that if that paper is true and a sing
then what staff recommend to us is what
we're but we're Bound by and I'm not
sure that's a good place to be
so I'll just quickly respond
um near Clark so under the local
government official information and
meetings act uh the decision-making
Powers rest and staff that act does that
uh that being said uh
counselors get to make the decision
whether an item goes into public
excluded or not that is a separate part
of the decision-making process under
leguma to what we as staff are able to
determine it's not at any stage to
intended and if it has come across like
that then that is not my intention that
staff have the final say so on whether
something's public excluded released or
otherwise
it is something that we all work
together on
I guess that's the confusion and the
wording I think so the part that seems
under the volume of the me and
counselors are not able to make
decisions on the release or otherwise of
information so as we head into a meeting
if you put up a paper that clearly says
we can't release it then we're forced to
go to the PE whether we like it or not
we don't have any choice if that's a
correct statement and I'm not sure that
it's the case because we do have a
choice about peers
if you're recommending to us that the
paper can't be disclosed so again it
would depend on the nature of that paper
but more importantly the the stage of
the decision making process
um if council's indication was that it
would have to be released
staff would need to discuss with you why
staff were recommending that that matter
wouldn't be released but once the
decision has been made on public
excluded what we are suggesting is that
staff are going to recommend when
something can be released but that
ultimate decision making on releasing
their paper vests with Michael and no
ultimately Michael as the chief
executive
it's not I will never
do this council's decision making stage
and your powers around this first and
section 38 which is your decisions on
when you go into public excluded or not
so just what I have done there is I have
perhaps conflated the two stages of
decision making
um for both staff and for Council
and I apologize that could have been
clear
just wanted some clarity around there
I saw some hands up over here before
long Leslie seriously
I was just going to reinforce that
section 13 5 of lagoima is talking about
the process for papers that are already
in committee and when they will be
released so this is a totally separate
conversation from the ability of council
to decide whether or whether or not
something went into Committee in the
first place this is solely talking about
the release of papers that have been in
the committee okay
um which is is 13.5 says
the decision
ultimately the chief executive and
obviously with the advice of other
officers
um
13 13.5 is quite clear about that when
the papers are have been in committee
papers taken in committee
it is the in the chief executive who
makes the decision about the timing of
the relief of the release
um
so yeah I think the the slight confusion
Mia Clarke is that you're thinking about
the original decision about something
about whether whether something's in
committee at all which is a totally
different discussion from what
this is dealing with really
yes you know thinking that we're going
to have a new counselor shortly these
sorts of
yes these reports that come to us set a
sort of a picture of where where we're
at and I think don't they they're not
commenting on a policy they're just
saying here's the report this is the way
forward so um and it's very healthy that
we have oh sure now a paper for felt how
there can be a managed process of
release of release of a lot of papers
that we know have got no particular
reasons for still being in the committee
but I suppose just
stayed in committee for lack of time or
policy to decide that they would be
released so I I think the paper is
quite a productive proactive release
paper
Darren on our prolonged discussion that
was my point yeah thank you
so do we go back a meeting or do we
leave it on the table if you want to put
some clarification well I'm happy to
move the recommendation that we received
the report and I'm happy to see
is going to be in place yeah and I think
for that mayor Clark your point is um
I've taken that on board and it will be
part of our induction for the incoming
counselor to help with that clarity
but I guess if we don't if we just take
the document the way it is it still
opens it to the confusion that Leslie's
raised
I will and one of the issues I initially
faced my first camera Council was about
four or five years ago a few years ago
seems like a lifetime um
was that we often use the provision it
says we went in the PE to allow for full
and Frank discussions I just where we're
at now about being transparent with the
community I just don't understand that
commercial sensitive you can understand
yeah um stuff that relates to staff all
the individuals you can understand that
but to leave it open that you can use
there or anybody could use it I just we
tucked away them way too much you know
we don't do that now and I get a lot of
questions from other councils that have
heard about us live streaming workshops
as well saying how's it going you know
what are the pitfalls
um I said well not not much
yeah so if you prefer I'm very happy to
uh take the paper and um reset it and
bring it back to the August meeting I'll
be happy for that just wonder what's up
with those with that Clarity we're gonna
move her on a signal
or just receiving the report um
we can receive an immense okay yeah all
right okay happy to do that so the
motion is just to receive the report and
we'll leave that to you Michael to come
back to the next one all those in favor
hi okay thank you
so we're on to tab 11. which is the
issue that we had in the workshop on
earlier today about the STV versus first
past the post system
thank you mayor Clark I will um I have a
very short presentation
um first I just want to acknowledge uh
the uh massive amount of work that the
community engagement team did Rihanna in
her team but especially Emily who has a
return to France and I would say warmer
climbs or maybe excessively hot climbs
at the moment she did a stellar job for
me out on the engagement hustings and I
greatly appreciate her effort so if she
is watching us on the live stream thank
you Emily you think the chance
absolutely
but so and in terms of the rest of it
and you've seen the outcome of our
consultation with the community
um it is uh quite interestingly split uh
from that uh generally uh younger people
uh tended to be in favor of uh STV our
youth Council I think you've heard from
them in the past uh very very strongly
in favor of
um moving to STV conversely when uh the
engagement team were down and Bluff
Bluff was pretty much unanimous in its
opposition so it was uh quite an
interesting uh set of results
uh you've also had our Workshop today
just to take you through some of those
pros and cons and one final thing that I
have come across that is actually quite
interesting that malavik is just going
to pop up on the screen for me as a
little demonstration
of the STV calculator in action so there
you see and people are voting for their
favorite celebrities it's not who I
would pick but that's okay
do you know who they are
[Laughter]
well I may be younger I am not there
young
um so basically the voter has now ranked
them um I can say that it's not how I
would rank them either but that's okay
are you able to enlarge it a little bit
yeah
[Music]
if you just go control plus plus plus
plus did they say Orlando Bloom
who no no no no I know
Mal and Brando John Lennon Marlon Brando
or that
there we are thank you
thank you right so this is how
yeah
thank you
um so next
so what
um my voting preferences are not
not relevant to this discussion
um so right so the votes are all counted
and our nice calculator okay next
I'm getting Kitty right so the red line
tells us as Warwick explained earlier uh
that's the total number of uh votes
divided by the positions plus one
so you've got that so everyone who has
put their first preference in uh as you
can see brendo and Monroe are both over
the line so they will be considered
elected
oh look there we are I'm Advanced so the
rest of the so all the other votes for
the people who said Marilyn and Brando
and Monroe are my first elected people
then will get redistributed to their
second preferences
and then some people only voted for one
person so they only voted for Marlon
Brando because they just loved him so
much
um
that's it they don't their votes don't
go anywhere else their preferences
aren't distributed uh and so the
um oh you've gone fast so they get to be
calculated uh so that's dropped out and
this becomes not transferable which
changes the quota it goes backwards so
the next round which we just saw there
um basically they've worked out that
Elvis sadly the King has left the
building because there's no chance he is
going to get elected so his um so all
his second preferences so the people who
voted for him on their first Preference
they all would then get redistributed to
the next
um the second preference
so we can go to the next one
and then those people
um do it again go through Audrey drops
out and John Lennon becomes our third
counselor
and again so you get your
non-transferable votes of those people
who've only given one or two preferences
so this process continues until everyone
gets elected so it was actually quite a
useful visual demonstration of how the
STV calculator Works
um it is available on our website as
part of our STV uh consultation
and with that I will now leave it to you
for your discussions but I'm here for
any questions could you just get that
back and go back to the start yeah
so then click the next one and the next
one
so actually what happened with all the
transferable voters that
three or Scott through
yeah so there were um so you shuffled
all the votes up and you still got the
same outcomes yeah because they were
simply
Audrey and um Airlines this wasn't the
best example
just compared to them they weren't all
right
I've been favored by these voters
so we basically have a choice I'll come
to you in a minute ring
um
interesting in the discussion before the
workshop
um that the young people
and you're getting probably too old for
this now Alex but the young people
the really young people that I interface
with say they like STV And yet when you
do the the round of the the last
election
um the groups that were targeted towards
the young people and the young
Professionals in town we had more
candidates here than we had people
listening to us so it's interesting that
we know that
a bigger majority are older people that
vote on these sorts of things having
said that
um we have the best results in the
country and I know 51 doesn't sound
great and I think last time it was 55
but the next one it was I think was 30
something so which is pretty diabolical
will we locally get more participation
if we have single transferable votes or
do we turn off some of the older people
that just say it's too complicated
normally I won't be bothered so my
personal preference is to stay with
first pass to pass but happy for people
that want to discuss it we'll just have
to have a show hands on which one we go
to anyway
there
so maybe conversely there was a low
turnout at the oips because they don't
like the first past the post voting
system I I um
supported fpp
um when we last had this vote uh it was
it was an interesting split
I've spent
the last while having a listen to the
youth Council
and working with them as they went
through their process and I think we've
had a couple of occasions where the
youth councilors have been along and
spoken to us and we've been you know
quite impressed with the with the way
that they've been able to express
themselves they've been running uh an
STV voting system for their processes
for five years now yeah right about that
I think my son was the chair when they
first started doing it yeah he's been
exonerated
um you're compromising conflict of
interest sorry
um
now we're I'm prepared to give it a go
and it's tough because there's a real
split in um in the in the feedback that
we've had and I think we'll find it's
it's going to be a a close call this
afternoon
I've always said if you can explain it
in a sentence it's nice and simple this
TV is not able to be explained in a
sentence but
when you listen to the three or four
sentences that explains it does present
a slightly different perspective
um
and if we want to try and increase
engagement then I'm I'm prepared to to
look at it thank you
rangi
um thanks chair look
um going back to the last election
election I talked to quite a few friends
and people on how they vote and and
under fpp they still look at money
voting for five six I'm not voting for
12. and and putting myself in their
shoes and they're looking at six people
I want all six I'm not going to rank
them I don't that's the six people I
want on my Council
um and and then if we look at the
agreement for for a disability people
and they go oh that'd be a good
voice to have on Council I want that
person I don't want to I want them all
to have the same power that vote is the
same for everyone I'm going to give them
a tech and there is no difference I'm
not writing them one two three four five
six seven or whatever so all of those
ticks I've given have the same weight
and that's what I like about fpp is that
ability that you're not having to sit
there and go ah who's better Bob or
Bruce or whatever so and ranking people
now
to keep it
for people I reckon it's easier to
participate people want to see their
Council they can imagine it they might
not get 12 but they can tick seven of
them and they equal have that weight so
I'm definitely for fpp Barry yep I'm
totally in favor with springy of
first-person post I've talked to a lot
of people
major a lot of people all the time
99 of them have said everyone first pass
the post because it's not confusing
Maria
um thank you Mr Mayor I think it was
really good for this Council to put the
question out there to our public our
voting members to give them the
opportunity to put submissions forward
and actually give us their view of
whether they want to SUV or fpp I've
gone through this so I just want to
bring some fix forward in case it's been
lost in all the information for us to
look at today
we have a population base of over 57
000. we had 68 submissions coming
through 37 of those wanted to change to
sdb 31 of those wanted to stay with FF
sorry first pass the post that equates
to 0.12 percent
of our public putting through a
submission on this looking at that I've
been we've all been told today that we
don't need to consult with our community
whether to go forward with this or not I
think it would be full Hardy of us not
to do that given that information that
we have had in this document we don't
have a clear mandation to go forward and
change how we are voting there are other
issues that come up for me today through
um our workshop and those issues come
around the fact that we know that we're
facing an uncertain future with lgnz and
how we're going to look like in the
future we know too that from some of the
reports coming out that that looks like
it will be a directive from
um what a new look future with councils
is going to be my concern at the moment
is that we have people going hungry we
have people that have not got enough
housing we've got so many issues in our
community
just as equal we have some positives I
think it would be okay for us to
actually wait
until we have a firm directive as to
what our future is going to look like I
think it's not going to make us look bad
or be undemocratic to anybody
um out there in our voting public or our
community so actually does have a bit of
caution and wait to see what our future
looks like and what our futures for our
communities look like under local
government local Council I also noted
that it says that this was a cost
neutral exercise
and we looked at what the um count could
be for STV votes in the workshop and it
said it was twelve thousand dollars 12K
but we didn't actually have the
um information there to show what our
first pass the post was
um and I want to just just quickly I
really believe heavily in our Democratic
right to have a vote in New Zealand what
I did not appreciate and although it
might have been in a joking gesture was
for a Pom-Pom poll to be taken
I did not appreciate that at all
um that's just my personal opinion it's
not anything against staff or anything
um democracy is
really important in this country and I
didn't quite appreciate that a Pom-Pom
vote could be taken as to
what the flavor in the room on the day
was for
um those attendees for for lgp but I'm
at this stage
um
I'm happy to to wait and stick with our
first Pastor post let me see
thank you Mia Clarke
um so as the only person in the room who
has been elected both in first past the
post and STV elections
um I just wanted to say right at the
start
first pass the post is actually all
about ranking
when used when you vote in the in a
first past the post-election you are
effectively ranking the candidates
whether or not you put a tick or a
number beside them you are actually
ranking the candidates in a first post
election and you were saying I'm voting
for that person or I'm not
um
one of the big advantages with
proportional systems of which STV is one
is that they are not only fairer more
representative and usually bring more
diversity in their results
but they allow for Less wasted votes
because they actually allow your ranking
to mean even if your first choice is not
going to be successful the
redistribution of your second choice
means that your that some of your votes
are going to count
so to me
STV has actually got the ability for
more of your votes to count and less of
them to be wasted in local elections
um also for me
proportional systems and STV is the one
we're talking about
do have a lot more engagement in them
and look we've already had a number of
Elections where STV has been the voting
type or the Health Board elections last
time were STV elections many of those
were on the same ballot papers as first
pass the post elections so people were
using two different systems to vote
there was not a remarkable increase in
the
destroyed or invalid voting papers as
the result of people using two different
voting systems on lots of ballot papers
throughout the country in those
elections people got it
part of the reason they got it was that
there had been a lot of engagement on
STV voting and the fact that an STV you
needed to use numbers not ticks
older voters that I spoke to throughout
last election were very clear on that
younger voters yes by and large
favored is TV a great deal more but I
don't think and I'm talking as a member
of the older generation I don't think it
is a valid reason at all to say our
older voters want to stick with first
pass the post because it's what always
what they've always known because there
are a lot of older voters who are very
confident voters with STV and with MMP
as another proportional representation
system and have Illustrated that Through
The Years by turning out an elections
that use those proportional
representation systems and filling out
their ballot papers quite well for me
the advantages of STV
um being fairer more representative
meaning that more votes overall count
and fewer are wasted
um just means that the time has come
to actually say let's let's change to a
proportional representation that gives
people more ability to find at the table
at least some of the people they have
voted for with the STV votes
either
yeah thank you Mia Clark
I have spoken to a lot of elderly people
in my daily rounds of the town
and look
STV is so confusing for them it's
manipulating figures to get a different
answer but we should make it easy for
everyone to vote and encourage them to
vote we want more people to vote
just going back to the last Southland
District Health Board results
there were 2
496 informal votes and 4
450 blank votes all wasted wasted
completely
so that people out there have spoken
that I've spoken to and it's not half a
dozen it's quite a few hundred actually
uh and look it's we want everyone to
vote make it easy for them to vote so
that's why we should be sticking to
First past the post
all right I'll just have the last
comment and then we'll oh sorry Evelyn
conversation leading up to MMP
the world did not end that's right
um
it's sort of kind of interesting if I
were to go and look at my son's
generation so the 30 years something
year olds
um they would wonder why I may you know
why we're making such a big issue out of
it democracy is democracy
just because it's always been the first
person in the horse race because we've
always had the Athletics model or
whatever doesn't mean to say that it has
been the model that is best suited
um true democracy I think we're making a
decision not for what we do in the next
three years so much as what our children
and our grandchildren do going forward
I
like to think that we can actually put
aside what we think is the best for us
and think about what is the best
because I would like to see more young
people feel energized by democracy
not turned off by democracy and when it
looks like it's old people standing in
their way
I think there must be a turn off I mean
I think if I if I look big to win my my
grandmother told me that she voted the
way my grandfather said because he was
the man of the house we've moved on a
lot since then but this is in my
lifetime that is in the
1970s
that sort of attitude doesn't Prevail
anymore
but do we still hold on to something
that actually comes out of a time when
not everybody was enfranchised
you know so this is a system that has
been around that has suited the power
plus if you like for a long time is this
not time that we actually think about
what the young people are saying to us
that there is another model that they
actually see the potential in it
and try it because we tried MMP and it
did actually give us a different
composition of members of parliament and
while some people don't like it other
people have rejoiced in it more women
more diversity
um all those sorts of things and I would
really like to see this city
think about this and this table to think
about this
because if we do the same thing we've
always done we'll get the same result
we've always got
Alex
um thank you Mr chair I'm sure it's not
going to come as any surprise to you
that I'm going to talk to is TV system
um the future for local government
report has been really clear that in
months of fastidious research and into
in consultation with communities right
across the country
government local government all sectors
of our communities uh you know
right across every sector
um is extremely comprehensive report and
it's very clear that STV is the fairer
system for local government
I've always found it really interesting
that we get to vote on this we get to
vote on how our votes are counted in our
community and I find it really
interesting that we get to vote for this
because it's a little bit like asking
turkeys to vote for Christmas
it's incredibly self-serving in some
ways like we actually get to choose
whether or not or what way we think will
apply to us or we can apply to us and to
ensure that we get our seats back on or
get our seats back
um so I really want to urge you to be
brave and not to think about us but to
think about the future if we're thinking
about 10 20 years time in the future yes
we have a future for local government
report but whether or not that actually
gains you know some significant Traction
in the next few years was you to be seen
but for the council that comes next do
you want people who are voting for who
those people are in the community do you
want to strengthen their voice and make
sure that every the entire preference is
counted or just the single vote
it's actually can be explained in one
sentence and it's just literally just
vote for your preference one to ten
doesn't matter how it's counted we know
that we're doing that by the books we
know that the algorithm is provided it's
literally that simple there's no
manipulating figures to get a different
answer it's literally just one to ten or
one to thirteen or what you know you
don't even have to vote for your whole
13 you could just do your first favorite
sex you can do your first favorite
whatever everyone still has the same
voting power the same weight it's just a
different distribution system
honestly invercargill deserves a fair
voting system I truly believe we should
be thinking about future councils and we
should be setting ourselves up and our
future up for the most Voice or the most
strengthened voice and the most voice
voices to be counted amongst that
I think I'm going to leave it there but
elected bodies with broader
representation is most likely to be
reflective in an STV system and we've
been able to see that in history
um yeah we'll just leave you with please
be brave
all right
yeah just have to sort of pick up on a
couple of points there Alex people get
12 choices when they vote for the
council not one yeah so you know it's
not just one vote we get 51 turnout here
and we're an ecmv you look at those
other councils that are STV and their
votes a lot lower you know I agree with
Peter's Point around the fact that you
know this is about getting people to
exercise their right in democracy not
confusing them about how the voting
system works and I think there's a real
risk that we put people off if they have
a confusing system I think we've got to
be
really work hard to get more people to
exercise the Democratic process and and
so and I also pick up on what rears
talked about where invariably what's
going to happen with the local
government decisions and next to it
probably not next time but
excuse me the following term as a
decision will be made anyway so why
would we go to a cost or can you know
risk of confusing and disengaging our
voters stick with the system I've got
and then you know central government and
I the other point I want to raise is you
know I see this as a little bit of a
sort of cop-out by central government
instead of taking it to a referendum
themselves they're asking local
governments to sort of be the testing
ground and see if it's popular and then
run with whichever toilet runs with so
you know I think they lack a bit of
fortitude and if they really believe
it's the way forward then come out with
a referendum and and get into it and all
the polling shows the referendum would
be in favor of single transfer sorry if
press bust the post so you know I just
can't you can't well I support the first
pass the post because of those reasons
Mary yeah it worries me that everyone's
bringing up this MMP carry on because
that's probably one of the worst things
that happened to our government
cause we've got more input a lot more
MPS than we need just yeah we went down
that road and it to me it's not
successful at all I do know there are
two former MMP members and I don't care
I think you have to be a little bit more
on to understanding how that works and
making a generalized statement like that
saying mate
Leslie's going to have the last word
before I wrap it up
that
[Laughter]
um the statement that it's clear that if
there was a referendum
uh first past the post would
come out on top is rather put the lie to
by the fact that the last referendum on
a boating system in New Zealand
delivered MMP a proportional system so I
think that that really happened
um
yeah I I've see it all like or I've seen
as much as I can about why why we should
be brave and go for single transferable
vote I've said it before and I will
continue to say it and it's fine look
I'll put it to that in a minute just a
couple things for me I don't have any
skin in the game as you know because
next section I won't be here
um I'm worried that if we uh Tinker with
the system that we've got a whole lot of
other reform going on in local
government anyway
um we potentially we've got this wrong
risk the fact that we're the top Council
in the country for voting patterns have
been for quite some time I think we were
51 and previously 55 the national
average was in the mid 30s they're
nearly 20 15 lower than us
um
I don't think young people are gonna
vote because we've got STV or not I just
think they don't vote they're not
interested in local government politics
they're instant whole lot of other
things the only way for me in my view to
um
together the young people would be have
online voting and the government's not
brave enough to go there yet or the
Electoral commission isn't I think
you're right grant that um it's really
interesting that um the general election
for the electorates
it's not held on this TV it's first pass
to post
and again while the while the document
yes it is Maria's looking at me
strangely
let's first pass the place for the
electorate MPS
and then on the issue of 16 year old
voting in our election government's not
brave enough to put that to the general
election either so you're quite right we
are a bit of a testing pot for that
um
yeah
I'll just move on and have a show of
hands for those that want the Rope
either way so those in favor of the
status quo which is the first pass the
post
if you raise your hands
oh Jesus sitting on that side of the
table is a bit risky isn't it okay two
four five six and those for STD
one two three okay carried in favor of
first pass to post somebody somebody
would like I won't ask you to move the
Motions
somebody on this side of the table would
like to move the the four
recommendations with um first pass to
post and and get number two Grant and
bearing thank you all those are five say
aye all right Karen would you like your
opposition noted certainly right Alex
and Leslie both have quarterbacks
excuse me can I just get some
information around the last boat on it
46 first past the post 16 single
transferable vote
um
that's the last poll on the voting
system
46 in favor for a single Trend uh first
passes close for where for New Zealand
what poll were you talking about yeah
one online here
uh we can't see your iPad sorry well
Google it the New Zealand voting system
referendum yep
okay
one more
so to item number 13. it's
um tab tab 12. temp 12. those of you
following along so this is the
opportunity
um about once every three no bad
thirdly doesn't sound quite as good as
quarterly we try and bring the
attendance we just we've got uh to you
so that you can make any corrections
that you may notice in there
um as noted first time around it's
something we regularly get leguma
requests for
so uh if you if you've got some issues
and the ideal is to
um just email them through to the team
and I so we can correct that and I thank
you councilor Cricket we have noted your
apologies and uh for the
um
extraordinary the community well-being
fan meeting and the extraordinary one
that you did put an apology in for that
was um missed by my team so that is our
fault
um does the apologies um that we were
spoke about uh in PX the other day get
carried over that will be that will be
corrected from today and sorry sorry for
my period of leave yes yeah okay yep as
discussed at that last meeting and then
also finally uh with the new email
method of sending apologies into the
mayor and to the governance email that
should help alleviate some of these uh
inaccuracies that we've got because
while my team are awesome and I give a
shout out to them and we're also human
I hope so
do you want the corrections uh so if um
I'd rather than taking time today
because it is quarter past five just
email them through to
[Laughter]
I think Michael day may have wished to
hit something
no that that you've covered off what I
needed to cover off Michael thank you I
think so just for my industry to
reinforce uh email apologies please
um if you're stuck something you need to
ring me that's fine and I'll make sure
that Michael gets to know
if we start putting Michael day and
malavika and other people Helena into
the mix it just the messages go all over
the place
so it's important that yeah just to
email the right people yeah and then
you've got to track yeah I've shared
that governance email with you all so
send that to them my team will have
access to that so that we will make sure
it's recorded
um
so I've got one late item which um so I
just hit one one through the comment
you'll reach it um a while back we also
had a conversation around workshops and
attendance and workshops
um and I remember we've spoken about
um like you know additional commitments
like for me Charlotte and work and stuff
like that and we'd spoken about whether
or not it was mandatory to be in
attendance at those workshops or whether
or not because they were being live
streamed online that if I was unable to
make one I could just watch it online
make sure that I was still across
everything
um I guess I'm still a little bit
uncomfortable then with them being
recorded as does not attend or did not
attend and then being like I guess
advice merchment on people's attendance
when like if they have maintained that
they're up to date with the content and
making sure that they're um being
um active participants it kind of look
do you see what I mean it kind of looks
like a black mark on someone's record
when we've spoken about it previously
that it wasn't mandatory I think in the
classification that Michael's got on the
uh on the recording
um if you're not a member you're not
required to be there so that clarifies
part of it if you don't want to be a
workshop some people have work during
the day and some of these workshops go
all day other people have other
commitments as well that's a call you
have to make if I start smudging that
and saying well you've got a daughter to
look after I'm not pick them on you but
it will well Darren's got work to do
down at his work then we could end up
with two people at a workshop and
everybody else is as ticked as being
there because they've looked at the live
stream two days later so we definitely
don't want that and we and we've tried
to very much to restrict the ability to
zoom in as well because that's been hard
to manage and not good for the public
and having said that the level of
participation at the workshops this year
compared to previous years has been
outstanding
um yeah I absolutely do understand that
and of course you know I make every
effort to be there where I can I think
it's it's a bit more things like when
workshops are scheduled with quite a
short time frame to be able to move
things around to get there and also
things like we had a period that we
agreed at the start of the year for our
meeting membership I'm sorry I'm meeting
schedule and we had a week in July that
I planned my holiday over that was meant
to be a week of no meetings at all and
through that we had an EO meeting
scheduled in it and an entire like
pretty substantial ltp Workshop that I
would have appreciated to be at so I
guess I'm just flagging that you know
some of us do have like we try to plan
as much as we can we try to be as agile
as we can
um but it's just it can be a little bit
challenging to have to drop everything
at the end of a hit I'll come to the
element ring and and for it also to look
like a black mark if that's you know not
yeah it's the agree yeah totally but
again the alternative is we started
accepting excuses and then you're asking
me or somebody like me or Michael to
modif to make a value judgment now we've
got some counselors who just select not
to come some workshops they're not
interested and the records will show
that that's their choice how does the
public differentiate between the people
that elect not to come and it might not
be because they just don't want to come
it might just be that they've got other
work or they choose to do other work
they have some options around there
people have got child care I mean where
do you stop all this
um
the public want to know look I I
honestly don't believe that the public
are going to judge anybody by their
attendance rate because
um and Alan won't mind me talking about
this but
couple of years ago when he was a
younger man before he started his family
he was in Vietnam for a while and he was
quite absent about that but people I
think look at the quality of the
participation when you are there not
whether you're not there on one
particular meeting out of four I'll take
that as a compliment your wish yeah I
don't think people thank you I mean I
get feedback about who contributes and
who doesn't contribute
um we've got a lot of that
I don't see that as a black mark Hello
Maria's looking sheepishly there now I I
think um no Mia Clarke If people could
apologize for workshops it's an easy way
to capture the fact that you can't
attend you can certainly counselor quick
and I'll take your point on what
happened in that week of July that
wasn't Our intention when we sit that
week
um to be free
um so we will work with our planning
teams to make sure that where we've got
those weeks set aside that they are
actually kept free EO meetings are
accepted because there's not a lot we
can often do about that workshops I take
your point Thank you
there's a similar Point really because
there's
I'm making every effort to attend all
the workshops and all the meetings
but in actual fact because it's not an
expectation that
we should attend some of these things if
we I were to apologize for example for
risk and Assurance this morning it
wouldn't have been recorded because I'm
not expected to be there and I think
that fears that's that's the situation
that a lot of us find ourselves in we
try and come the fact that we're not
always able to doesn't mean that we're
not interested or that we don't
um because there has to be some other
way I think of recording this as opposed
to
um did not attend or
um
what's the other one
in I you know which is not not
applicable yeah so I mean if we are as
non-members allowed to apologize for
those things and that apology to be
received I think even if it's not
recorded in the minutes if it's
acknowledged on these spreadsheets would
be helpful because I think it shows
about people's engagement yeah so I
think we could do that for workshops and
workshops as they relate uh committees
we would need to keep that because the
fact you didn't attend a committee
meeting that you're not a member of
you're not expected to be there
um and if you you choose to come along
and we acknowledge that a lot of
counselors do it is recorded in there as
um in attendance which is ATT but as a
non-member so that we can keep track of
it
um yeah we don't want to try and make it
any more complicated then
it already is but it is information that
we regularly get asked for and we do our
best to compile
some more subsequent question as well
must be up on the website tomorrow
morning well it's part of the agenda but
no we do not publish it separately
so the the issue we had last last term
was that um
we had the whole Council approach which
means everybody had to be on all the
Committees and we went away from that
and good that we did
um this term because it's really
important that people beyond the
Committees where they have an interest
otherwise because we end up with a lot
of apologies or abs and tears and more
people just sat there and said nothing
to the whole medium yeah couldn't wait
till it was finished and it was really
obvious so
you know it's all good stuff and I'm
quite happy to uh explain to people if
anybody wants to know that um if you're
not a member of committee there's no
obligation to be there if you wish to
come along that's great but if you're
not there's there's no obligation
because we don't want everybody at every
meeting that doesn't achieve anything
people want to come along because
there's something on the agenda they
like that's that's great to Barry yeah
um I'm sorry ring
oh great bring you first
thanks look I I think around the table
we have a there is a complete respect
for all elected members and that if
someone's not here they're not here for
a bloody good reason and they're just
not here the fact that the way it's
recorded I've got no problem you can put
a big black market pen beside it or
whatever it's really irrelevant you're
not there because of a good reason and
end a story
and it's not a tally that yeah you know
um you know get get remunerated on or
get censored on so I I see no problem in
what Michael does at all as I said
before I think
last time we did the ltp review which is
the cycle we're into now some of the
workshops at the end of the end of that
cycle we were getting three and four
people to it but it must mean
debilitating the staff to come along and
present for a couple of hours and have
two thirds of the councils basically not
not interested anymore so it's a creator
that we're getting really good turnout
this time and I think part of that is it
people have got the message if not put
the effort in then we've got to be here
to listen to where we can't bury yeah um
as far as that last second Workshop we
had just recently uh I invertently sent
my apology to Darren because I thought
he was cheering it
so I did pass it on yeah
it is it is very very difficult for the
cheers
now I know yeah that's right no we're
not here I can have the people
listen
as long as as long as members of the
public read the legend as well as
looking at the actual
filling in the The Legend covers
everything and I think as far as the DNA
goes the most concentration of the DNA
has actually been in the workshops
and I think it's probably a timely
reminder to everybody that you actually
do need to apologize for workshops
which we are all expected to attend
as much as you need to apologize for
Committees of which you are a member and
I think perhaps people have gotten to
a habit of thinking of workshops is
another category where an apology is not
necessary and I think it's a good it's
just a good reminder for everybody to
apologize for workshops just as you
would for a committee meeting
I mean I expect members to to manage
their workloads both workloads here and
elsewhere I mean I skipped a few
meetings recently or gone out part way
through I mean I'll mix officio on
everything and I started by thinking I'm
going to attend them all and I'll get
100 but there's times I need to go and
do other work other Council work and I
look through the agenda and I think well
there's actually nothing there there's
all that
needing up my attention or input so I
make a choice or I can go and say the
check and you as I did this morning can
you do item four first and then I need
to go so yeah I think that's all good
stuff
almost anybody Aaron Darren's the lucky
last one excellent what a way to finish
um he says I'm modestly yeah like I
think attendance is is way better now
than it used to be I was at a couple of
those workshops last year when they were
to governance members and and uh and a
lot of staff and it was a little
disheartening particularly for the staff
but I balance that off with the fact
that in the last term we also had a hell
of a lot of workshops around working on
working together yeah and it did
absolutely exhaust counselors and and
our time and our ability to manage um
other roles that we have so it is easier
but I would also note that actually it's
starting to creep back up again
um and we just need to be
I'll be quick now expeditious and how we
deal with business yeah
just a move on a second of them
um
thank you all those in favor I carried
we've got one late item which I signal
early on which was from the risk and
Assurance committee this morning you've
all had a copy of that and it just talks
about
um the table Yeah the order proposal and
fee approvals so it's just at the end of
it it's just authorizing me to sign away
279 204
um yeah
oh that was cutting
Jesus if you flake out with uh it's
recycling I'm going to give you some of
those tablets yeah
um so um Grant you were there you wanted
to make mention of this paper
around
the audit fee
um in the you know how the ears have
been worked out and you know I think um
personally myself you know I was in
favor of a fixed price contract to just
make sure all the New Zealand you know
are fully committed to getting it done
and getting it done within the ears
which have estimated noting the fact
that they've underestimated the years in
previous war it's quite substantially so
um it was my only view but the committee
I've had discussions with Michael to my
right and um
with Bruce and with the order New
Zealand lead as well around this whole
issue that it just seems to be a blank
check
um driven this year by hours of work
driven Last Time by extra work I mean in
in between two orders we've gone from a
forecast of 170 and potentially next
year up to 370. when you just can't
justify it so we've got some serious to
work to do on that committee as we go
forward to say hey
um it's all right to keep adding to the
ordered pile somewhere along the line
and that's got to be enough and we've
got to say hey look there's some stuff
you've been ordering for the last five
years and found nothing wrong just leave
them aside so that we get less of those
hours kicking in
yeah but having said that the hours that
they have proposed which is around 1500
yeah is helpful because it could really
be a dump site more than that
if you go on the previous figures yeah
yeah
okay I'll move on a second for that
thank you grant
let's see all those in favor
aye Kerry yeah we're going to uh
publicly Miss gluten yes
move that way yeah and your Sidekick
Darren's got a second that all those in
favor
you can stay Stephen because I know
you've got